Dark Souls 3 spin out a while and you
might think that you know everything
about it but don't underestimate the
depth of what this community can
discover that sound you heard at the
start that was a voice clip from the
dances opening cutscene but reversed and
only less than a week ago
reddit user center noticed that
reversing the dances sound clips reveal
their haunting original sound honestly
I'm surprised they didn't use these
sounds instead next there are two
versions of the handmaiden in the two
variations of Firelink shrine one in our
light and shrine and another in the dark
shrine which is connected to the rest of
the overworld and the question is are
they the same person and if they are is
one in the past and another in the
present well if you talk to the untended
graves handmaiden before you talk to our
one then our hand maiden recognizes us
and gives a tiny bit of unique dialogue
at the start oh god oh isn't anything
ashen one I am but a humble handmaid of
the shrine so this makes it clear that
they're the same person right and it
also lends credit to the theory that the
dark enshrine appears in the past
because she recognizes us remember well
I am undead
bound forever by the shrines course the
shrines are intriguing
and there is a lot more to say so I'll
try to make a video on this area soon
the earliest mention I found of this is
on integers YouTube channel so credit to
him for recording it for sure
one thing sold by the handmaiden is the
budding green blossom which becomes
available for ten Souls when you get to
the part of Cyrus's questline where she
goes to kill Heydrich the interesting
thing isn't that it's ten souls it's
that it has an extra sentence in its
description that all the others don't
have
it reads goodbye dear grandmother I will
visit grandfather in the pit of Hallows
and if you look closely you'll see that
these flowers are tied with some string
like a bouquet this might become a
knowledge at this point but I came
across this discovery when Jackman
triple7 tweeted the hidden sentence at
me and I couldn't find it in any
description I looked at until I looked
on the Extra Life wiki and it had all
the information there so does this make
the hand maiden the grandmother in the
description or was this bouquet
something that the hand maiden stripped
from a grave outside the shrine she does
have a habit of accumulating armor sets
from corpses after all for number four I
loved the discussion that came from the
threads made by ether moth and dha'fi
mum who put forward that each of the
unconditioned axles three have a link to
a Lord of cinder on re2 oldrich secret
to yawn and Hawkwood to his legion we've
talked before about how it's a nun
Kindles duty to place the cinders of
Lords upon their Thrones and each
unconvincing and it's not too
far-fetched to think that we are their
corresponding unconditional Ong with the
others as those with the highest chance
to uphold their duty and bring the
Lord's way
associated with to their Thrones you
should really check out the discussion
going on in the link in the description
because there is a lot more to be said
on this topic I think it's an awesome
discovery also in filing shrine have you
ever had the fire keeper turn away from
you this happens if you wear the untrue
dark ring or the untrue white ring which
are rings that reference the deeply
detested hollows of lond or so is she
turning away from you in disgust this
was first posted about by savior ji and
then again by spirit I 6 with more proof
I tested it to and I could never get the
fire keeper to turn away without the
ring on and without being hollowed so
it's undeniable I think that this turn
has something to do with the Rings and
perhaps with the hollows of Londo as
well right so let me know if she
exhibits this exact same behavior for
you guys as well it would be good to get
some more tests out there I think
because some people have been reporting
that she turns away without the Rings on
for them but I could never get her to do
it
without the Rings 6 is probably the
biggest longshot on the list but I still
think it has merit to it three months
ago Chronos Trinity pointed out that the
shrine handmaid has unique dialogue for
the Dreamchasers ashes which are the
ashes that you found a top Ferren keep
behind the illusory wall and he or she
also points out that the hand in these
ashes clutches appendant action 1 what
woeful umbral ashes this this barren
dust stuff of a fool won't yield aught
clinging to lofty dreams in this dying
world
more's the pity
it must come from one most foolish
indeed in Dark Souls one finding meaning
for this pendant starting item became
this long-running challenge and then
joke of the series because the series
creator Miyazaki mentioned that he liked
to select the pendant himself personally
and later he admitted that the pendant
was a bit of a prank intended to keep
players guessing at its purpose for in
this game full of secrets how could such
a thing be meaningless right so is the
handmaiden poking fun at whoever's
clutching the pendant other creators
making fun of us for clinging to these
lofty dreams number seven is a
relatively recent discovery for how
amazing it is so around three weeks ago
user Scarecrow 13 over on the extra life
forum posted this exhaustive breakdown
of how he deciphered the runes upon the
titanite slab in Dark Souls 3 and his
interpretation is that every symbol line
describes a different historical age in
the series he roughly translates line
one to the meek sort God slash the
divine in the trees egg drasil The Tree
of Life bestowed the gifts of plenty joy
and health line two they remained and
hardship set in they found a spark which
turned into a son driving away the cold
and the ice terrible trouble came the
Sun ended this conflict line three this
age continued and began an era of wealth
and plenty man will ascend cold and ice
will return Scarecrow stresses that
there is a great deal of personal bias
involved in anyone's interpretation of
these runes and these symbols including
his own bias so I really really
encourage you to read his article on the
topic because your interpretation serves
a really big part in this as well it's
crazy that this could go undiscovered
for so long
moving on did you ever do a visceral
attack on one of the pontiff's beasts
but not finish it off when it was
vulnerable the first post I can find on
this is by GN link 34 whose post got a
ton of attention about three months ago
to me more than anything this helps
cement pontiff Sullivan's character
because he was the one responsible for
these beings becoming this way he was a
tyrant a man with twisted morals who
transformed his own men into these
beasts and yet it's clear that some of
these beasts humanity it still remains
and they are either begging for mercy
here or they're praying in desperation
the next thing is that honoré has a
unique piece of dialogue and interaction
if you execute Horace while there along
the path of sacrifices oh don't leave me
don't you don't like the others Oh
Horace horse that's gonna be in the
prepare to cry script Horace everyone
forgive me
I was weak on my own and finally
something I wish I knew in my last video
the comments section called me up on
this so there's this statue in lower
lothric and user who Toto points out the
links between it and pontiff Sullivan
first this statue holds the profaned
great sword which is a weapon wielded by
Sullivan and this weapon also references
him when he was still a young sorcerer
second the bracelet that the statue has
is the same as the bracelet on
Sullivan's right arm and you might think
you know okay a few reused assets big
deal from does this all the time but
this statue linking lothric and young
Sullivan it's a huge deal if you watched
the angels video then you'll know that I
talked a lot about how the lothric
bloodline and the sorceress of the grand
archives rose together they were very
close and I also said that the first of
the scholars played a part in convincing
the young lord lorik against the linking
of the flame and the pontiff is this
character that really does go against
the linking of the flame as well so he's
a huge candidate for being the first of
the scholars this character who
convinced lothric not to link the fire
and additionally the pontiff's gear
looks a lot like the candlestick
scholars of the grand archives so it
seems pretty clear to me that Sullivan
might be responsible for convincing
lothric not to link the fire and that he
might be very much responsible for the
defection of the Deacons of the deep
away from the way of white for the fall
of Lorex bloodline and basically for
most of the events in the game before
you go I've got one thing to ask of you
guys and it's not to like this video
it's instead to go and send some love
and some friendly mail to the people I
featured in this video to read their
contributions and to continue supporting
the incredible discoveries of everybody
in this community
because I'm just happy I can be a
platform to display and discuss some of
this stuff also why the [ __ ] is there a
crab in the ball
you